PRIYANKA: If you are
ingesting large amount of data
for analysis or
looking to simplify
the development of event
driven microservices,
then you need to check
out Cloud Pub/Sub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Pub/Sub Made Easy.
I am Priyanka.
And in today's episode, we will
dive deeper into Publishers
and see some configuration
and application design choices
you will need to make when
building a real world Publisher
application.
A Publisher application
creates and sends messages
to a desired topic
on Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub offers at
least once message delivery
and best effort ordering
to existing subscribers.
While publishing
messages to a topic
when using JSON over
REST, the message data
must be base64 encoded.
The entire request, including
one or many messages,
must be smaller than
10 MB after decoding.
The message payload
must not be empty.
It must contain either a
nonempty data field or at least
one attribute.
What can you include
in the message itself?
Well, here's the message schema.
You can embed custom attributes
as metadata in the messages.
Attributes can be text
strings or byte strings.
A server generated ID
unique within the topic
is returned on the successful
publication of a message.
If you would like to see
an example of publishing
a message, check out
the previous episode.
All client libraries
offer an asynchronous
API where your
application does not
have to wait for the
actual published request
to be complete, although
synchronous or blocking
mode of operation is
supported as well.
Check out the link in the
description below for the API
reference documentation for
your choice of programming
language and its support.
The first decision
you have to make
is how to batch your messages.
You can configure
the client library
to send multiple
messages per request
to the service based on
the size of the buffer
or time the client waits
for the buffer to fill.
Batching has the
obvious advantage.
The larger batch size
increases message throughput,
which is the rate of
messages sent per CPU.
Asynchronous client
libraries try
to publish multiple batches in
parallel for higher throughput
but it also comes at a cost.
It introduces latency
for individual messages,
which are cued in memory until
their corresponding batch is
filled and ready to be
sent over the network.
To minimize latency, batching
should be turned off.
This is particularly
important for applications
that publish a single message
as part of the request response
sequence.
However, the additional
network and computing overhead
may make small
batches preferable.
You'll have to tune your system.
Messages can be batched based
on request size in bytes,
number of messages, and time.
You can override the default
settings by defining your own.
Here's an example
code in Python where
we are defining batch settings
for maximum bytes, latency,
and messages.
A caveat here is that once
you override one setting,
you should override
them all explicitly.
Now here's how this works.
On the first message
that you send,
a new batch is automatically
created with a countdown.
For every subsequent
message, if there is already
a valid batch that is
still accepting messages,
then that batch is used
to drop the new message.
The batch is published once
sufficient time has elapsed,
maximum messages has reached,
or maximum bytes is met.
By default, the batch
setting is set 0.05 seconds.
Now what happens if
publishing fails?
Publishing failures
are automatically
retried in some
client libraries.
Check out the
linked documentation
to check the support for
the language of your choice.
Because we are dealing with
requests over a network,
request failure is a normal
part of life and understanding
retries is essential.
Client libraries support
custom retry settings.
Here's a snippet
with retry error code
received from the publisher.
Here's a snippet with
retried parameters
that include timeouts and delays
with the default settings.
The main two parameters
to understand
are the total timeout, which is
how long the application will
keep retrying before giving
up, and the initial timeout,
which is how soon it
will start retrying.
The total time out depends
on the typical availability
of your network, the memory
available to your machines,
and application
specific considerations.
All right.
So today we learned
how to publish messages
in Cloud Pub/Sub,
different options including
synchronous/asynchronous
messages,
and setting up batches
and custom attributes.
Join us next time to learn more
about setting up Subscriber
to receive messages.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]